Merhaba
sevgili gençler Merhaba hepiniz
hoşgeldiniz şimdi yok sahibinden soy
yapımcı ve yönetmenin benim hayalim ve
Hayallerim Çocukluğumda başladı Aslında
bizim dönemimizde
Şimdiki gibi dijital dünya yoktu
sinemalar vardı Hatta ve hatta yazlık
sinemalar vardı tek eğlencemiz ailemle
birlikte hafta sonları o sinemalara
gitmek o sinemalarda filmleri seyretmek
ama ben maalesef Beyazperde hiç bakmadım
kadrosu
arkamdan gelen sinema makinesinden çıkan
o ışığın o projeksiyonun peşinden koştum
hayatım boyunca aklımda hep o odaya
girmek gereği girmenin yollarını
araştırdım makine dairesine a ve e
İlkokulu bitti ortaokul bitti Ortaokulda
da bizim dönemimizde 16 milimetrelik
filmler oynatılır the sabahçılar ve
öğrenciler olmak suretiyle Arada sırada
sinema makinalarından filmleri
gösterirdi 16 milimetrelik Tabi ben
filmi hiçbir zaman seyretmedim okulumuza
gelen o projeksiyon makinesini ve o
projeksiyon makinesinin nasıl
çalıştığını merak ettim ve sinema
makinesi ehliyet almam gerekiyordu bunun
içinde bizim dönemimizde liseli
Bitirdiğin zaman üniversite sayılıyordu
Ben de liseyi Endüstri Meslek Lisesi'nde
bitirdim Daha tabiatta Elektrik
bölümünde bitirmem lazım olsun ama
makinesine gel diyetini alabilmem için
ben uzun olduktan sonra hemen belediye
başvurdum ve en profesyonel olarak sıkma
makinesi ehliyeti ve almıştım ikinci bir
hedef kapandı koydum bu filmler nerede
nasıl çekiliyor onu çok merak ediyordum
filmlerin Yeşilçam'dan geldiğini o
dönemde Yeşilçam'da büyük bir sektör
olduğunu Türk sinemasının ve tüm
filmlerin orada
çekirdeğini öğrendim bugün atladım
Beyoğlu'na gittim yeşilçam'a lise
çağlarımda makine dairelerinde
çalıştığım dönemlerde öğrenmiştim
yönetmen de filmi çekiyordu Ve hedefini
ben o dönemde koymuştum lise bittikten
sonra ve belge Öğretmen olmak istiyordum
bunun içinde yapmam gereken en önemli
şey
bir yönetmenin Asistanı olarak başlamak
tı Ben de o dönemde bu filmlerin
çekildiği Türk sinemasının döneminde
bölümde çok böyle keyif aldığım ve bana
rehberlik yapan iki üstüne ile birlikte
çalıştığım Ertem Eğilmez ve Metin Erksan
Halit
trafik gibi ustalarla çalıştım ve Artık
yavaş yavaş bu dünyanın içine girmişti
makine makine daireleri nden yeşilçam'a
Yeşilçam landı kamera önünde oyuncularla
birlikte çalıştığım dönem başlamıştı
bizim dönemimizde ne o kadar çok
sinema-televizyon okulda yoktu
o usta-çırak ilişkisi bizim için çok
önemliydi ustanız verdi ki hadi Göksel
hazırsın bu filmi de sen çek artık
noktaya gelmiştim Türk sinemasında tam
15 yıl bir kare film çekilmedi Evet Ee
bugün çok etkiledi çünkü hani koyup gibi
bir yıl 2 yıl gibi bir süre değildi
benim için tam 15 yıl ben özellikle
Aslında benim için çok para bir dönem
başladı ve bu kara dönemden sonra da da
ne yapmam gerektiğini bilmiyordum ve TRT
başvurdum TRT ye girdim TRT girdikten
sonra da kendim o dönemde geliştirmeye
başladım Eğer sinema çekilmiyorsa Ben
TRT'de program yapacağım programlar
yapacağım belgeseller çekeceğim diye
Nitekim öyle oldu TRT girdim TRT
girdikten sonra birçok belgesel
çekmeye başladım ama bu arada
Yeşilçam'dan Ustam Metin akşam da orada
hayatımız tekrar kesişti bu orada Metin
Hocam Işıklar içinde uyusun evden şey
demişti Yoksa böyle iş yap ki yaptığın
her iş belgesel 5 kitaba 5 kitap kadar
değerli olsun yazar Bu kitap kadar
değerli olsun diye bir cümle sarf
etmişti bana Ben de bunun ne olduğunu
anlamadım ama zaman içerisinde
ilk filmi çektiğimde 1994 yılında
Ayasofya ile ilgili
abone ol
[Müzik]
bu
dünyanın bir gün parası olarak kazandığı
askeri başarılardan çok ıstanbul'a
kazandırdığı ölümsüz uygarlık kalıpları
ile ünlenmiştir Rusya Rusya evinde
İstanbul Köprüler kiliseler çarşılar ve
Su kemerleri ile dolmuştur
1994 yılında Yaptığım bu belgesel
uluslararası birçok ödül aldı bu MHP
daha yaklaşmıştım Çünkü böyle film benim
için çok önemliydi
artık milyon etmen kimliğiyle çıkmıştım
1994'te bütün toplumdaki seyirci önüne
ve ilk yönetmen olarak orada mıydın
kendi filmini çektikten sonra ödeme daha
büyük bir zevk aldım Bu yönetmen
kelimesi ve hedefe ulaştığında bir
yönetmen kelimesinin bu kadar benim
nerede sürüklediğini Şimdi daha iyi
anlıyorum Evet Çünkü yaptığım işlerde
Her zaman şunu kendim de benim sevdiğim
Yoksa kendine diye dek oy oy Hedefte onu
yap Ne Ondan sonra gör bu çıkar
çıkardıktan sonra orada Ne yaptığın
hataların neydi İyidir e1o gömlekle
yüzleşir dedim yani ben bütün çektiğimde
o filmden hatalar yaptığımı kendinle
aynaya bakarak düzleştirdim Aslında ki
tek Rakibim vardı kendimde ve zamanla bu
değişti ve filmler filmler filmler
derken Ayasofya'nın derinliklerinde diye
bir projede çalışmaya başladım Bu proje
dediğim için çok çok önemli bir projeydi
Ayasofya'nın altındaki tünellere
araştırıyordu biliyorsunuz Roma Bizans
döneminin
İstanbul'un altındaki ayrı bir şehirdi o
dönem önem
[Müzik]
abone ol
ama
onun dışında Burası tehlikeli biraz
çünkü
[Müzik]
Evet
Ee Hayatınız boyunca bazı belgeseller
vardır Çok uğraşırsınız üzerinde Ama bu
uğraştığını zaman zaman o kadar çok Akar
ki siz doğru bir şey yapıp yapmadığınız
endişesine kapılır kapılırsınız ve bu
endişeler zaman içerisinde büyür Bende
bu projeyi yaparken böyle değildi şeye
katıldım ve hala da üzerinde çalışıyoruz
fakat bir an öyle bir an geldi kini
Sabah uyandım Uyandığımda bir
arkadaşımın telefonuyla dedi ki Göksel
dedi ben buranın kitabını aldın mı Murat
edip almadım Şimdi ben buradan
kitabından senden bahsediyor dedi Allah
Allah dedim Şaşırdım çünkü hani dünyanın
en büyük yazarlarından bir tanesi ben
Duran internet kitabında yani şurada
ve
bu kitapta
84 bölümü açtığınızda benden
bahsediyordu çok şaşırmıştım ve doğru
bir iş yaptığımı
arkasındayım ve bu da benim için çok
büyük bir Onur kaynağı oldu ve bana çok
büyük bir motif motivasyon oldu
bu kitapta yer almaktan dolayı çok mutlu
oldum Ayasofya'nın derinliklerinde şu
anda yapım aşamasında bitti Fakat yarın
sofileri yaparken Ben bir başka bir
projeye devam ediyordum sağlığının
projesi sadna'nın projesinde azalmıyor
hastası bir kadının hafıza kaybının
hikayesini anlattım projeyi dört yılda
ver zeytin gerçekleştirdim Bugün
günlerden ne söyler misiniz Cuma 1900
dediğimiz 2000'lerde miyiz
bu neredeyiz götürürse götürsün
o
insan öleceğini de bilir ama asla
kondurmaz
uzaymer olmak da benzer bir iş İş
hayatın sizi ne zaman nereye
sürükleyecek belli olmuyor ama ki
hayatın gerçek yüzünü de tanışana dek
salonun projesinin çekimleri bittikten
sonra hepimizin bildiği komit dinlen
ondan et salgın
hayatımıza girdi birlikte bir hayatımıza
girmesiyle kalmadı Bir de Hepimiz
evlerimize mahkum etti Bu yönetmen
olarak bir film bitiriyorsunuz ama
filmini sevgilim sevgiler biliyorsunuz
ve oku süreç geçen iki yıl inanın Sizin
kadar beni de markette Çünkü
hayallerimizin peşinden
koşup bu filmi yapıp o filmin sonucunda
alamadan sanki hayatınız yarıda kalmış
gibi böyle kendimi bir böyle içme
kapattım
eve kapandı ve
kendinizle kaldığınızda geleceğinizle
ilgili ve filmle ilgili o kadar önemli
kararlar alıyorsunuz ki
aslında komidin bir de bazı böyle kötü
olayların iyi tarafına bakmak gerekiyor
Evet ben de bu komik meselesini tarafına
yönelmiş Team
evdes Adana'nın ile ilgili gelecekte ne
yapacağımı projesini veririz ettim
gerçekleştirdim Nitekim de komik bitti
arkasından film galası yapıldı Şimdi
film festivallerinde Yarışıyor sizin bu
süreçteki kararlarımız bu süreçteki ne
yapacağınız Bu süreçteki ne yapmak
istediğimizde doğru orantılı bir dönem
bu hem benim için hem sizin için çok
önemli bir dönem Aslında
Sizlerin de mutlaka hayalleri vardır
hayalin peşinden koşmak kadar güzel bir
şey yoktur aslında ha bundan sonra da
dünyanın başına ne gelecek bu sonra
dünyada ne olacak komik gibi Sizler de
ben de Hepimiz yaşayarak Göreceğiz Ama
ne olursa olsun önemli olan
sizin kendi hedeflerinizden asla ve asla
Şaşmaz Hatta şimdi şöyle güzel bir söz
geldi aklıma
içimizin derinliklerinde
bizim oraya koyduklarımız dan başka bir
şey yoktur Aslında Siz kendi içinize ne
koyarsanız koyun o içimizdeki ve büyünün
ve içinizdeki yaptığınız hayallerle
sonsuza dek yaşayın eserlerinizi bırakın
hedeflerinizi seçin ana Hayal kurmayı
dokunduğunuz Hayallerinin peşinden
koşmayı asla ve asla bırakmayın teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]